let's try to name this molecule right
over here and so the first thing we want
to do is identify the longest chain of
carbons so let's see it could be 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 or let's see maybe it's 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 yes indeed that's the
longest chain and if you go 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 or 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 so those aren't the
longest so the longest one is this one 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10 carbons and this
is going to be an alkane because it's
all single bonds and a alkane with a
alkane that's a chain of 10 carbons we
would use the prefix Dec for 10 so this
is a decane let me write that right over
here this is a decane decane now let's
think about the groups that are attached
to this decane so we have this group
right over here this has two carbons in
it one carbon two carbons and so we
because it has two carbons we would use
the prefix F remember meth is one carbon
F is two carbons and since it's a group
that we're not talking about the
backbone this is an ethyl group this is
an ethyl group and we have another ethyl
group right over here two carbons
attached right over here this is also an
ethyl group and now this group right
over here is interesting we can count
the carbons in it so it has one two
three carbons so you could think about
well this has three carbons our prefix
for three carbons is proq so you could
say maybe this is a propyl group this
right over here this right over here you
could say maybe this is a propyl group
and you wouldn't be completely off-base
by saying that but we have to be a
little bit more kick a little bit a
little bit more careful when we name it
because a propyl group you would assume
that you're attaching to one end of the
propyl group but we're not attaching to
one end of the
purple propyl group we're attaching
essentially to the second carbon to the
middle carbon and this is a secondary
carbon the reason why it's called why
it's called a secondary carbon is
because it's attached to two to two
other carbons if it was attached to
three other carbons it would be a
tertiary carbon if it was attached to
only one carbon it would be a primary
carbon so you could call this since
we're attached to the second the
secondary carbon right over here this is
sometimes called a sec a sec propyl
group a sec propyl group and it's also
sometimes called isopropyl an isopropyl
group isopropyl and then you'll actually
see isopropyl a little bit more
frequently and these are these would
both be referred to as common names
common names for this group now if you
wanted to name this systematically then
you would do it very similar to the way
that you would name the entire molecule
you would look for the longest chain
here and the longest chain in this
molecule starting starting with where
you are attached is a chain of two
carbons is a chain of two carbons and so
you could call so that the backbone
right over here is ethyl is let me write
this right over here is ethyl
it's an ethyl backbone here and then you
could have you could view this carbon as
a group attached to that ethyl backbone
and we would start counting we would
start counting right where we are
attached to the main chain so this is
the one carbon this is the two carbon so
this right over here this is just one
carbon group this right over here is an
methyl group or a methyl group this is a
methyl group so you have a methyl group
attached to the one carbon of an ethyl
group so the systematic name for this
and this is a little bit less typical
for for a group as small as a propyl
group but you could call this one methyl
one one methyl one methyl ethyl one
methyl ethyl is a systematic name for
this now the systematic name you might
say hey why go through the pain of doing
this for something so simple that we
could just call isopropyl this is useful
if this was a much large
a much more complex group that was
attached to this main chain but more
typically and this is why it's called
the common name you'll see this thing
right over here just called isopropyl
and sometimes you would call it C it's
called a sec propyl or even s propyl now
that we've named all of the groups let's
think about what carbons they are
attached to and where we can start
counting from and the way that this is
done is that you would start counting
from the end from the end of your carbon
chain your main this kind of this decane
backbone and you would count from the
end that bumps into the most groups
faster so for example if you count from
this end this would be the one carbon
two carbon three carbon four carbon five
carbon on the five carbon we bump into
two groups if we started over here this
would be the one carbon two carbon three
carbon four carbon five carbon on the
five carbon we do bump into a group but
only one group and we'd have to wait
till a six carbon to bump into two
groups so so we get to the two groups
faster we would start counting on this
end so this is one carbon two carbon
three carbon four carbon five carbon six
carbon seven carbon eight nine and ten
carbon and so when we think about which
one which groups are we going to refer
to first do we refer to the ethyl groups
first or do we refer to this isopropyl
group first we just think about the what
what letter they start with in
alphabetical order so for example these
ethyl groups they clearly start with an
E
they clearly start with an e e comes
before in the alphabet then the I and
isopropyl before the P and sec propyl
you would normally ignore the sec or the
tert when you're thinking about
alphabetical order and a also comes
before the comes before the M in methyl
ethyl so we will talk about the ethyl
groups first so remember our backbone
ten carbons all single bonds
it's an alkane since there's ten of them
it is decane and so let's talk about the
Ethel's first and since we have two
Ethel's we can say that this is diethyl
so let me write that down
so we can write diethyl die ethyl and of
course we need to specify where those
two Ethel's are one is that the five
carbon one is at the six carbon so we
could call this five five six diethyl
that refers to the five refers to this
ethyl group six refers to this ethyl
group and now we could talk about the
isopropyl group the isopropyl group is
also on the five carbon so we could say
we could say five six diethyl five five
isopropyl ISO propyl isopropyl decane or
if we wanted to use SEK propyl instead
of isopropyl we could write SEK propyl
here or if we want to do the systematic
naming we could call this five comma six
die die ethyl five instead of writing
isopropyl here we could write all of
this one methyl ethyl here so actually
let me just copy and paste that let me
just let me just copy this one methyl
ethyl right over here copy and paste let
me stick that there one methyl ethyl and
of course the main backbone is decane
decane decane so either one
all of these are reasonable ways to name
it this would be the common way where we
use isopropyl here we're doing it more
systematically by calling that group one
methyl ethyl